aux etats-unis pour pallier au manque
d'organes et face à des listes
d'attentes imposante c'est par internet
qu'un américain a trouvé deux reins dont
il avait besoin un site spécialisé qui
met en relation donneur et receveur avec
les risques éthiques que l'on peux
t'imaginer nathalie sapina alain du bas
à gauche
un homme de 58 ans atteint d'une grave
maladie rénale à droite celui qui lui a
donné un de ses reins l'intervention a
eu lieu cette semaine dans cet hôpital
américain et c'est une première parce
que le malade a trouvé son bonheur sur
internet grâce à un site web privé
officiellement sans contrepartie
financière
ils attendent un rein depuis cinq ans le
donneur âgé de 32 ans affirme agir par
pure charité jambes
la transplantation a duré quatre heures
et s'est bien passé des web est en forme
ça a marché c'est bien mon papa va bien
en france un tel marché est impensable
les dons d'organes entre vivants sont
strictement réglementées et réservée à
la famille proche
frères soeurs époux parents et c'est la
justice qui les autorise le juge vérifie
que lanson la procédure a été gardé que
l'autre par le juge vérifie bien la
gratuité du don la loi française punit
lourdement celui qui achèterait un
organe jusqu'à sept ans d'emprisonnement
et 100 mille euros damende aujourd'hui
6500 personnes attendent terrain parfois
pendant plusieurs années une pénurie de
greffons que l'on ne réglera pas par
internet et ses risques de dérives et
par une augmentation significative des
dons d'organes
un père us